what is going on with Nintendo the
secretive company aren't giving away any
plans for their disappointing we you run
or the next console the NX I'm Kate and
this is your please understand news
update following a report from Japanese
newspaper Nikkei earlier this week
saying that the wii u would cease
production sometime this year presumably
to make way for the secretive NX
Nintendo has responded denying the
rumors the statement quotes Nintendo is
saying the Nikkei report did not come
from within our company Nintendo
reportedly further clarified the company
plans to continue production through and
beyond the next fiscal year we have
reached out to Nintendo in the US and
are awaiting further clarification so
keep an eye out for further updates
while Nintendo's latest console has been
less successful than the ubiquitous we
ceasing production entirely this year
would still come as a surprising move
however if the NX has backwards
compatibility it could quickly render
the wii u obsolete we expect to learn
more about Nintendo's plans for the
future during this year's e3 are you
disappointed in Nintendo's recent
business decisions did you actually like
the wii u let me know in the comments or
come and find me on twitter i'm at how
not to draw thanks for watching and fro
your gaming and entertainment news keep
a gamespot